first there was light
and with that came shadows the light why
should correct what's underneath it now
imagine a world without shadows right
rather it's not an optical illusion to
head under this is the future of light
Wow computer algorithms can calculate
where light isn't and fill in the dark
spaces try that with one of Edison's
incandescent bulbs commander sweat
fred max ik is a physicist and
philosopher who founded a company called
lighting science
he believes that light is the last
frontier of the digital revolution white
is the last analog technology that has a
legacy of the Industrial Age every other
technology has gone digital
Edison gives the pond around mp3 players
look radically different with radically
different functionality it's the movies
DVDs video this video on demand the
structures completely changed lighting
is the last structure to go once you
digitize it light becomes more than a
source of illumination every wavelength
can be manipulated so precisely that
colors change before your very eyes now
imagine the commercial application in
surgery in retail in agriculture and of
all places in your bedroom max ik
invented a bulb heat claims can help you
sleep light can be a wonderfully
powerful drug actually we're just
learning as a public and as a consumer
to use it that way medical studies have
established that light plays a crucial
role in regulating the sleep cycle
there's a set of receptors deep inside
the eye sensitive to blue light the kind
you get from the midday Sun fluorescent
bulbs and smartphone screens that blue
light keeps you awake by suppressing
melatonin production
find a way to remove it cheaply and
you've got a product that could disrupt
two multi-billion dollar industries
sleep therapy clinics and insomnia drugs
and that's what lighting science is
trying to do the presence and absence of
the blue light that is the most
important cue that it's time to be awake
the thesis has already been tested in
space for astronauts being in space is
like working the night shift all day
without normal light melatonin levels
drop circadian rhythms go haywire and
sleeplessness sets in so lighting
science outfitted the International
Space Station with lights that simulated
a day on earth well good morning and
that restored the natural sleep cycle
now Fred max ik has packaged that same
technology in a bulb you can buy at Home
Depot he calls it the good night light
there's just one catch each bulb costs
70 dollars I'm not selling you a light
you turn on and see by I'm trying to
sell you a light that's going to do
something biologically significant here
in your life and there's some big money
betting max ik will succeed Pegasus
Capital a private equity firm has
invested a hundred and fifty million
dollars in lighting science we can take
a significant portion actually create
some of that market where it's not being
used today I think the real question is
how do we explain to people that what
they've been doing is caused
and that's really the biggest challenge
changing the way people have been
thinking about light for more than a
century when I think about what light
will be I think about life being things
I'll be built into building materials
light will be built into windows light
will be delivered in ways we have even
considered light will be completely
customizable to the user based on what
their needs are